kicked me in the ass but i'm telling the
truth the kids today wouldn't know what
that
is you were looking at the mob guys as
your friends
there's catania do you want to get a
slice i come from a boxing background
you're not going to screw around with
richard mancuso
my
that's what's missing if you didn't get
home at 5 30. you didn't eat
calabria and naples same with me crazy
seriously
antonia has not changed a thing since
the 50s huh
that's why i got so huge eating this
stuff all my life if you sit up on nabla
that's a curse and you better run go
back to florida
we don't give up we fight for our values
we believe in our culture
[Music]
good afternoon guys the best stories are
usually told through locals that have
history and experience so today we're
going to meet up with an old-school
italian-american rich mancuso
who's going to bring us into his
nostalgic lens
of new york city we're going to go
through his history here what he's seen
but also get his take on what things are
currently like
here in 2021
[Music]
oh
yeah you too good luck with everything
oh man the best you know i mean really
good italian regular italian food
but like the bread bakeries yeah you
can't find better bread anyway all right
so have fun thank you rich how you doing
we shaking we doing this what do you
want i don't know i don't give a
anymore
let me show you this first
all right we're in rich say hi
take this mask off first yeah okay
don't have to wear it outside of
something to wear when we go somewhere
in boys
yeah so this was all italian back in the
day yeah basically
in fact i'm going to show you now the
bronx kill okay everyone knows the movie
here's the mural
what's the movie the bronx tale god i
haven't seen it
oh wow do i need to go home now watch it
come back
you need to see it because everyone has
seen it she's based on this neighborhood
back in the 60s
there was the racial division
okay they didn't want any blacks or
latinos in the neighborhood
and the bronx tales based on that a lot
and about the mob
guys that try to keep the neighborhood
safe here's the mural of it right here
all right
you might want to see that they just put
this up a few years ago
you know when you think of italians in
new york you think of i mean
the tourists think of little italy but
this was it right this was known as
little italy it still
is little italy the bronx
we're very far from manhattan yeah
mulberry street's little italy of new
york but this is little lily of the
bronx
at one time this community would was
designated by the fbi is the safest
neighborhood in new york city how's it
now no
okay unfortunate and and i'm not
i'm not going to fault anyone yeah
but to tell you that when i grew up here
on these streets here and what we're
going to see right
the mob influenced the mob guys really
kept it safe it was the mob keeping it
safe not the cause
right the cops were you know the part of
it
they worked with them they worked with
the community we had a beat cop
ah you don't have that no more he had
one cop or two
that knew the whole neighborhood walked
around with the billy club
and when you saw that cop you ran away
because you didn't know
let's just say you have a business every
one of these shops was paying to the
italian mob
no okay and then work that way how'd it
work see that's a misconception they did
not control
businesses and people okay they were
very kind-hearted people that helped the
community
not like what you saw in the sopranos
with tony soprano and then making sure
that
they controlled the businesses took the
rent or whatever that's not what it was
like here
that's a misconception what what they
did was
protect the community they helped
people they made sure these streets were
safe
and as a result and they were put away
and the cops couldn't control
and then the landlords took a lot of
these buildings when section 8 and this
neighborhood changed
so how were they making their money then
they did things that weren't legal
we know that okay so were they selling
drugs or
not that wasn't a big one around them
not me i didn't see that
okay all of that might be going on i
never saw it
okay there was the illegal racket game
of numbers
okay gambling which now is not an issue
at all because it's all legal now
right this is the main street 187th
okay and you'll still see the italian
presence
with the pastry shops oh yeah that old
school pastry plus thin
are places that were in here when i grew
up
uh there's a little there are two sold
which was the most popular one down the
block
and we'll go see jerome if he's in
gino's pastry we'll take a walk
okay we're gonna go to a pastry shop
yeah we're gonna get some italian food
is that a possibility i was gonna do
that at catanias i wanna okay
sicilian and a mini calzone
okay guys the sponsor of today's video
is cuts clothing i like making videos
but i hate
shopping luckily i found the best
t-shirt of my life that works for
everything
from walking the streets in the bronx
with rich mancuso to sweltering heat at
the texas border to going out with my
wife for dinner
this shirt does it all the older i get
the more i realize that quality is
important cuts makes products that last
no stretching
worn out collar ironing or pilling i've
used and abused these shirts and they
are indestructible
and fantastic for traveling yes they
cost more than your average t-shirt but
you get what you pay for with cuts
they also have stylish hoodies and long
sleeve shirts if you want one of the
most durable slash
stylish t-shirts i've come across after
years of searching
here's the best one i've found at a
discount to receive 15
off your order click on the cuts link
below in the description
or use the promo code peter at checkout
again that's peter at checkout i
wouldn't recommend something to you that
i didn't fully believe in
or use myself if you want the best
t-shirt of your life
give cuts a try people come from all
over the country all over the world to
eat here
down here that's some of the popular
eateries here restaurants and even
beyond on another blog all right we're
going to go down there too i'm going to
show you where my old social club was
that
sometimes people don't like the way i
talk about it and i say that i'm
anti-is no it's not that i'm telling the
truth
right i am i didn't grow up my mother
and father
taught me and my two brothers never ever
to be
prejudiced and to hate okay to get along
with everyone
and that's what i've done all my life i
still do it grow i grew up with
latinos and blacks all my life that's
because i'm involved with sports all my
life
but never had any hate or never biased
with some group over another
yes i'm an italian and i'm very
very proud of my heritage yeah as an
italian-american and i always
will be yeah and i also feel coming out
of this neighborhood
that italians don't get the credit they
rightfully deserve
contributing so much to society and
every walk on facet of life
yeah from the arts to the culture to
to the food to inventions i mean enrico
fermi this one that one even christopher
columbus
yeah and now we got christopher columbus
that's under attack this is what i love
about your generation that we're
starting to lose a bit
yeah i'm not young either but this
authenticity you know this this
love for craft and like mom and pop type
shopkins
sort of going away young people it's a
young people today
in the bronx in the city and this is
everywhere but here
if they would not know what we did and
what we went through
times weren't easy what do you mean by
that well we
you're saying it's not as good now right
you're saying like it's going it wasn't
great back then either
okay but the one thing that was great is
we had
a stable household a mother a father
today that don't exist i mean i've
worked well
for half the people right i've worked
with kids all my life
and i see it more and more a lot of
these young people don't know who their
mom real mom is or
alone more so who their real dad is yeah
we always had that structure my house
and most in this community knew who the
mom and dad was
who the brother and sister was and and
that that contributed a lot to
making this neighborhood strong because
there was a problem
if a merchant knew you did something
wrong they knew your mom or dad
okay if a cop knew the beat cop music
something wrong they knew your mom or
dad
and that wasn't fun to deal with mom and
dad no it wasn't right but not in my
house
i have an italian american father and it
was he was
he was hard he was tired you did wrong
let him rest in peace dad died too young
okay you got the strat
yeah okay oh yeah
and if you saw that belt come out you
ran for cover
if you look above that blue yawning
uh-huh
well that's where the restaurant was and
that apartment window right there with
the air conditioner
is where joe pesci live
before he was famous yeah
so a lot of our big uh italian-american
stars
grew out of this neighborhood yes some
of them are transparent terry joe pesci
sent the great club of his youth here
sicilian calabria and naples
same with me seriously it's a crazy
seriously
seriously yeah so that's classified
italian-american
yeah you don't call yourself italian
though you
are but you're an american you're born
here an italian american
how many generations are you thinking i
can go back
because i'm tech you know my dna comes
from that part of the world
um but i you know i can't claim i'm
italian but i do
i tell you italian food does bring about
warmth we always had pastas every sunday
like made in my grandmother's pot you
know sunday dinner
just like they did in italy three
o'clock
it was on the table it was a vegetable
in my hand it was big
did yours always end an argument in
college okay
it wasn't just sundays it was holidays
right
that's just a part of how we are
what is that highly emotional right
there's an expression coming out of
naples in a tank or
you know if you said alfa nabla
that's a curse and you better run but
here's arthur avenue okay which hasn't
changed
except for a few years
few stores stick ball sponge ball
kickball uh johnny on a pony
yeah we we met a a
ping pong against the wall with a sponge
with a
with a spalding ball spades they called
it yeah uh
scully in the street with the caps we
used to take on what that is well what
we did is we used to go to the cars
and we used to we used to steal and take
their
tire caps and put that on a bottle cam
opener
and put that data give it friction in
the street and you had to just use your
fingers
like that and try and get it into a hole
like circles
okay and we all did it that was our fun
house kids today wouldn't know what that
is how'd that go over though with people
did you get the beat down if you're
caught no that was uh they helped they
played with us
all right
so you were looking at the mob guys as
as
your friends they made me
look at things that others wouldn't see
you know life okay
they tell you a story yeah
they would you wouldn't have that you
hear that we know that
what mexican music wild music whatever
it is
you didn't have italian music no not
like that not like that well the sis the
car systems weren't that good back then
well we did still we wouldn't do it it's
called respect
uh you're looking that is as
disrespectful very why because it's
because
it's it because it's it's it's noisy
and people don't want to be around that
you know why must you drive around in a
car make all that noise when there's
other people around that don't
it's totally unnecessary what are they
trying to prove by doing that
kick me in the ass but i'm telling the
truth
i'm trying it it tastes straight all
right i don't have the ring on my finger
you punched them oh yeah i knocked them
out because i come from a boxing
background so you're not gonna screw
around with richard mancuso but
i stay away from it but if you're gonna
attack me i'm gonna uh
i'm gonna make my point you're gonna
stand your ground sure all right
don't mess with rich wow i'm getting
older so like
my mom and dad love that place they
would yeah
no no it's owned by a jewish guy okay
and an italian figured that out
hey i got a joke for you if uh a jew and
an italian go to go into business who
loses money
italian always wins no think this
through a jew and italian go to business
together who loses money
who loses money the italian doesn't move
the money the government
oh all right go back to florida will you
look that then became a
umberto's clam house the one they have a
little lydia mulberry street
yeah and they since it's not no more
this used to be the movie theater in the
neighborhood known as chinelli's which
was other known as
the dumps we come here on saturdays for
the matinee the kitty matinee
watch a cartoon in a movie right here
but it was called the dumps because it
was filthy okay i mean
you know i got the names of thomas
because he would see a rat once in a
while underneath the seats
and scare the hell out of everyone in
the theater why watch it right it is to
be movie theater
chinelli's and uh there was one maitre d
who would be the babysitter for all of
us on a saturday
she she dreaded that job but she did it
she became the mother hen to all of us
though
okay so all the mom used to throw a
quarter from the window
and that was your afternoon in here it
was like a babysitter
yeah she'd send all the kids and come on
from the window she'd throw it down and
to go
as part of your allowance that you got
on a saturday okay
tell a kid today what an allowance is
they wouldn't know that
25 cents 50 cents would get your whole
day in here
your movies your soda your popcorn your
hot dog whatever you needed let's go
around now
it's a beautiful library broadcasters
writers
antonios
all right antonia has not changed a
thing since
the 50s huh look at he's he's hiring
the cows you want this bread yeah let's
let's try some
they were open i think like that wall
has not changed
so this is the secondary store which is
just
you know get the same thing this is
[Music]
freshly made every day bites do not
that's why i got so huge eating this
stuff all my life
i'll be back in a moment bye-bye
the market that you
[Music]
this was here when you were growing up
rich how far were you so was i uh but
i'm here 44 years
oh fresh how you guys doing it's okay if
i video this
all right no charge all right
you got all the sausages here get the
fresh
how you doing nine times the sausage
i've known him since he was a kid
you're right i've been that was 13. wow
what do you mean
52 years man what have you seen in the
neighborhood
i'm sure you could talk for hours on
that but what are the big things changes
you've seen well a lot of different
people different ethnic groups or they
used to be you know strictly mainly old
italian you know
descending immigrants you know now we
got a lot of uh
big influx of mexicans and albanians
good workers good people
yeah uh still the italians they used to
come here you know years ago where they
you know with their mothers right and
now they're coming back to basics
because you know outside this
neighborhood everything is like
supermarkets you're not going to find
nothing like this anywhere
else in the world i live up in rockland
all you see is cosplayers and bj's
this is like an endangered species oh it
is it is i mean there's not that many
left of us
left you know i mean it's really not to
find a butcher that knows so why aren't
the italians having the italian
americans having kids what's going on
why they're they're having kids why
they're not having kids wow it's too
expensive for them kids that's what it
is
i understand one two life has changed
that's right
too much today it's not like years ago
nobody wants
i got to be at six o'clock you know set
up the case but nobody wants to do this
type of work you know everybody now it's
all
all the technological savvy now you know
they don't want to get their hands dirty
work
12 14 hours a day it's impossible if you
find somebody that wants to work
if you don't have hair you can't work it
can't hire me
yeah i was born there so i came here
when i was 13. you were wrong literally
yes where yeah booyah oh yeah the
adriatic site yeah yeah yeah
the hill of italy yeah you ever go
bastard 13 oh yeah turn back about five
times yeah
what do you think when you go back to
italy and you come back to the states
what do you want well you know i would
love to
you know i love i love italy my question
about it i love the lifestyle
but once you're used to this after 50
years you know i mean it's very it's
very hard to go back to that type of
lifestyle i mean it's so much karma
you know they really they enjoy life
let's put it this way
but you know i don't want to say they
have no goals in life we came here we
struggle we struggle we're always
working always on the rush much much you
know
you want a bigger house you want to
cause you want to give a education to
your kids
over there it's more summer more like
calm there's no policy exactly there's
no pulse you know that's what i told my
wife
it's nice to visit you know months to
weeks to weeks but to live there after
you used to 50 years here
you can do it okay you gotta come back
here you know yeah so
so you're saying down the road when
you're a new generation
not for a long time but i'm just saying
there's no one coming in to fill the
place
no no it's it's all going to be
pre-packaged stuff
you know what i mean just give me on
youtube you already know we'll make
i'll put you guys link in we'll make our
own meatballs on
television
[Music]
you come here a lot yeah i'm not alive
at all
[Music]
on them
where i am a lot with the mets covering
the met that song
no lazy mary you can't stand it
i can't stand it because it's an insult
to italians
this is mario's original restaurant here
why because it says lazy well
lazy mary it insults italians the
italian woman and the female
[Music]
they're close it's a monday
there's pasquale's rigoletto
go uh let's go get a meal
yeah we'll stop in contagion after we
look at the columbus bust
see the neighborhood completely downhill
when you go past here
what happens past here oh you've got uh
activity that's good
it's actually open today
this was a move this used to be by the
old
columbus boys club they moved it here to
this park
and it's a subject of controversy
because columbus dated
it's guarded because there have been all
types of threats that knock it down
how do you feel about that uh dead
against it what did this guy
this is italian tradition leave it alone
leave it alone he's an italian he's a
part of our culture
leave it alone so you feel like your
culture it's like chipping away your
culture if this happens
okay you get attacked too much and to go
back to the days when the mob guys were
around
if they tried to do that it would just
be a threat
and go fur any further than a threat
that would be stopped
yeah thank you so much
this is that's culture
well built so leave it alone any of
those statues in the city
it annoys me peter yeah
this is preston avenue this is another
straight
had some good restaurants on the corner
down further antonio's
and my old social club which is no more
was
in the middle of that clock right there
social club we hung out
we had a club us young guys
24 7. that was our hangout
there's a lot of beer drinking a lot of
parties a lot of fun
grew up with all of them a lot of them
still are not around no more it was
great growing up before the internet huh
you had the one
oh yeah we had one guy named slim willie
rodriguez williams you're latino
and his neighbors they got along with
every attempt for the merchants the
people the old people
he was such a helpful caring young guy
willie died too young slim we called him
slim
and he ran that club made sure the dudes
were paid
he lived in there and he he passed away
in his sleep and
i i took that bed because he was one of
my one of my best
you know there's katanas you want to get
a slice yeah let's
check this out if he's
let me throw that away
[Music]
don't put that on camera because my
doctor don't want to see that oh the
cigarette
what am i gonna do you were you were
smoking rich well my doctor won't see it
yeah he won't see it
my vision has gotten worse you got older
and i got older
i'll do a slice of cheese pizza a lot
more than your vision got worse
a lot now i still write and do my thing
well
i don't get over here as much as i'd
like you used to get
[Music]
they're calzones you can't beat them you
can't beat the cows
are you guys brothers yes all right but
she's got a great sense of humor
he does yeah yeah i'm like they don't
make no money what about you
not me i ain't funny at all
so guys tell me you're you're italian
american
yes italian american you were born born
in italy yes
born in italy where collaboration good
pizza
straight forward new york new york pizza
a little crisp at the bottom
good amount of cheese
what is the bait naked
this is the mini calzone
that you could only get
at catanias when we've grown up you know
10 12
13 14 years old yeah after school
you dropped your books home you did a
little homework that you got
and you went out and you played 5
5 30 there was a bunch of whistles going
off
and every kid knew which whistle was
this
that meant dinnertime every every parent
had a different whistle
every morning on the window at five
between five and 5 30 p.m every kid
was at the dinner table
[Music]
right so and that's what's missing
that's right in society that's what's
missing because if you didn't get home
at 5 30
did you eat you didn't eat
you didn't eat you had to wait till
tomorrow you had a different menu every
night you had to wait till tomorrow
right and that's what's missing
differently there's no more discipline
at home
we got kicked in yes plenty of times
yeah
but we stay together
and it's missing right i said where do
you think things are going right now
there's no discipline these kids are
doing whatever they want to do
to be fair old older people always said
that though every every parents always
said that right
absolutely what do you think this time
is different you got in trouble in the
street
growing up here yeah and somebody yelled
at you
like another parent you did not go home
and tell your parents that you got
yelled at
by another parent because if you did you
were wrong
they yelled at you for a reason they
didn't yell at you for nothing
so so parents everyone's parents were
looking out for other guys
absolutely that was called
community neighborhood which you don't
have anymore
there's no more communities there's no
more neighborhoods there's nothing
done that's depressing guys because now
they want
the cops to be the community back in the
day it was somebody else's parent
that told you hey what are you still
doing here it's 5 30 don't you think you
should be home eating
right if they were out or coming home
from work or whatever it was no homeless
there were no homes you didn't belong in
that farm we had the neighborhood bum
you know absolutely miguel was still
around but he didn't sleep on the bench
no and then we had uh ozark
remember yeah
remember my first time in this
neighborhood it looks pretty good
it was so much better if you think this
is good
there was a lot of kids just kids
running around the streets and whatnot
there was there was
leaks in the in the neighborhood yeah
like for instance
[Music]
always playing ball that's a lot of kids
basketball league remember the best
quality
each block had their own team yeah
everything
and that's the difference we don't give
up we fight for our values
we believe in our culture and we're
we're united people
we might all have money but we have
everything you got great food
you've heard you've heard the expression
about attaining the la familia
this is it like these guys are not
friends they've been like family for
years
i don't see them every day sorry he said
i walked in here
yeah i mean i wish i could see him every
day but
that's part of that growing up lavalier
that's it you deliver this
yeah we're delivering right now where
are you going i'm going to adam's place
you're just going to walk it there no
ubereats
take care
[Music]
you're seeing it for the first time i'm
going back to the past
let's go to the old block yoki's always
been my favorite because my mother used
to make this homemade
this is where the mob guys were here if
they needed a favor for me they got it
but i didn't want nothing back in return
from them except their love he was in
charge of the neighborhood frankie
frankie
back then you didn't settle things with
guns and knives
those are the moves those are the moves
cannoli will always be a cannoli
now it's something i'm talking about
i know that i get emotional sneaking
away from mom and dad
hey sweetheart yeah but they used to
watch from the window
used to control this whole area who
controls the block now
this is your mother our father both
you cannot erase great memories